it's pick up basketball it's like us
going to the the playground down the
street and you got your five friends or
whatever and you're playing pickup
basketball with strangers and you're
going out and you're competing on a
level but instead of being i mean and
it's just like it like you there's a
point guard there's like a center
there's a forward there's a shooting
guard everyone has a certain challenge
you pick the kind of character you want
to play yeah you know tanky a support
person you want to do someone would
range who's doing an arrow you want to
be someone who's melee assassin who goes
in and just kills people and every
character has his strengths and
weaknesses
but we're playing like we're a team
we're a squad yeah we're a squad
and and i go you know it's a sport when
you're playing against someone who's
better than you and you can feel how
much better
just like on the basketball court like
yeah oh my god this guy's killing me
like i can't he's too fast
it's the same thing you're like
i'm trying to get away and the guy's
he's too good yeah like okay then i got
to get better yeah and i got to get some
defenses i got to get some i got you
start learning the things that you need
to learn for you to be better
[Music]
nice with me and hold me back all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your host
[Music]